well with some candidates on the
Democratic side flipping the bird to the
NRA while others back Trump style
immigration is not quite clear what the
Democratic message is for 2018 Brit Hume
is Fox's senior political analyst he
watches carefully he joins us tonight
what do you think the message is or is
there a national message the Democratic
Party is selling this midterm I think
it's pretty indistinct at this moment if
there is one Tucker and I think that you
know much of the party is so mesmerized
by Donald Trump and and loathes him so
deeply that that has become kind of the
central thing and the central theme that
you can see that the Democratic I said
but the Democratic Party appears to be
mostly about right now I suspect as time
goes on something more oriented toward
voters will come along but remember
Tucker the these candidates are running
in a party where 71% according to one
recent poll want Donald Trump impeached
so it's kind of understandable that
there'd be some focus on him yeah for
sure and most Democrats are of course
very anti Trump that's why they're
Democrats but is that a message that
moves people to the polls well based on
the evidence we have it seems not to be
working very well and the reason I say
that is that look look at the advantages
that Democrats enjoy going into this
midterm election first of all the
political gravity and any presidents
first midterm is always with the other
party and the average loss is more than
would be enough if they if they made
their average gain the Democrats would
get control of the house they had a huge
gap in what's called the generic ballot
you know Tucker that's the one where you
you ask people they'd rather vote for a
democrat or republican unnamed in the
upcoming election normally Democrats do
well on that ballot there there were up
but plus 15 or 16 at one point not very
long ago and now that number is down to
single digits and some number and some
polls down to low single digits which
suggests that whatever they're selling
people are not buying with the
enthusiasm that that the party had hope
for what will happen if they don't
retake the house well you know I think
they'll be agonizing reappraisal because
it's been you know we've been talking
about this blue wave that was thought to
be inevitable and may yet come
if it doesn't come obviously there's
gonna be a search for scapegoats and
we'll see what happens but this party I
think Tucker what we're seeing emerge
now is that for all the all the
divisions in the Republican Party
between Trump supporters and the never
Trump errs and so on and all the
divisions within the conservative
movement over that the divisions in the
Democratic Party or at least as least as
deep if not deeper and it's and at the
heart of the Democratic Party I remember
you saying in a speech not too many
years ago was not with Hillary Clinton
but she won anyway a candidate of her
stripe I don't think it could win this
time I don't know that you know a white
male candidate could win so here we are
and like you know the Democrats the
Democrats really have some serious
divisions to worry about and whether
whatever they come up with will be
appealing to a broad cross-section of
voters as obviously what remains to be
seen yeah a white male candidate could
not win I don't think a lot of the white
male candidates running for the
Democratic nomination know that yet but
I think they're gonna learn um do you
think that it moves in a the direction
of populist economics becomes the
Elizabeth Warren Bernie Sanders party
well I think that's the drift and I
think that excites a lot of people and
of course if you you know you look at
the attitudes of young voters now who do
not seem to have grasped the benefits of
of a market capitalist economy and don't
seem to be put off at all by the idea of
socialism
despite socialism's abysmal history
which is playing out even today in
certain parts of the world Venezuela
being the most conspicuous example but I
think that you know the party is is it's
pretty it's gotten pretty far left now
and a lot of old ideas that are you know
being passed off as kind of new ideas or
in the air and you know part of they
have to reckon with that because if
they've come up with somebody who's an
out-and-out socialist for president I
don't think they could possibly win and
I don't think you know and I'm not sure
how many of them will see but they'll be
awful battles over this their corporate
donors because the party is entirely
supported by corporate America are gonna
be pretty surprised when it turns out
they're sending money to Hugo Chavez
yeah well no but donator me thank you
yeah you bet Tucker sorry go ahead no
I'm just and say don't have
underestimate the ability of a leftist
candidate to raise money from a small
donation
and make a serious run for it Bernie
Sanders oh that's right that's right no
that's right I just think the Goldman
Sachs guys are gonna be pretty shocked
when they see what's coming hey great to
see you yeah Thank You Tucker